are you guys talking to each other
uh are you guys on break you're like
dude you won't even believe what i just
saw today is it constant
hearing of like visually is this a
location near facebook headquarters are
you offside give me a
visual of what this looks like in the
relationship amongst each other so that
give me a little bit of the optics there
all right so this was not so this was
third party it was not facebook it was a
third-party vendor named cognizant
technology solutions
and so cognizant had a deal with
facebook that they were going to take a
part of their content
and they were going to work with it
off-site so they had their own sites
and we did have some people from
facebook stopped by occasionally to see
how everything was going i remember i
saw one of mark zuckerberg's personal
lawyers there once
but for the most part this was while we
had the facebook tech to go do all the
stuff
and we had all facebook's content it was
managed directly by cognizant
and so going forward with that it was in
tampa florida
and it was in this place called woodland
center so it was just this kind of giant
parking lot kind of just in the middle
of nowhere
and it was just this small building that
had it there
and you walk into the building
they have um a security guard in front
of their all times
you're not allowed to bring any pen
paper pencils anything you could record
or like take any notes on not even your
phone so you can't have a phone on you
while you're working no you cannot have
your phone on you if they see you with
your phone they just immediately fire
you
and i'm dead serious they just they just
can you if they see the phone because
they're the way that they describe it is
all this is other people sensitive
content so they don't want anybody
recording taking notes anything which i
understood for like the phones but for
like pencil paper they didn't even allow
that in there
so you go in there
and basically you have these two
incredibly small bathrooms that only
have about two toilets two urinals in
the mail bathroom and i believe just two
toilets in the girls bathroom
and this place housed about a thousand
people so it was terrible conditions for
the bathroom
and so you have these two small
bathrooms then you have this kitchen
area
and
it was just a very small cafeteria it
was just very banal there was nothing
really there
they did set up this little store there
and every week they would give you
twenty dollars on a card
and you could go eat uh whatever you
wanted to
as long as you didn't go over your
twenty dollars at this little store
but
for some reason all the food there was
junk food and sometimes they would have
like fruit cups salads but
all the people that were higher up got
all those so it's like the team leaders
the trainers they were able to get the
good food
and so everybody else was really just
eating junk food all day and what really
kind of hurt me a lot is i would see
this graphic content
and
what my people would tell me is like hey
go grab something there go cheer
yourself up so i grab like you know
chocolate milk some donuts and i put on
a lot of weight while working there i
actually weighed over 300 pounds
when i left
i have lost about 41 pounds now since
then
and i put on some good muscle i'm very
happy about that but um
it was a very unhealthy lifestyle just
not for me but for everybody that was
working there
so
after that you just had these two main
wings
and they are just filled with computers
there's no cubicles no nothing they say
that they wanted it all open
but
it was just nothing but computers
and there was nothing else there for us
they had this one tiny room in the back
corner
what was supposed to be like a calm down
relaxing room where it's like if you
need to calm down after seeing this
content you could go in there they had
like legos they had like a little
billiard board and all that but no one
was ever allowed in there
because they would like time you
obsessively if you ever got up from your
seat
so it would be like if you go to the
restroom they would literally put a
timer on your computer
and if it goes over the amount of time
you're going to get yelled at by the
boss for going over the time
if you're on a break and you're like a
minute late from your break
the computer alarm will go off and it's
immediately going to tell your
supervisor that you're not there
and even if you're just like right
around the corner you're going to get
another warning you're going to get you
know dock and pay
so they were very like
obsessive with you being at your
computer at all times
in fact what was just really ridiculous
with it
is how
there were people there that wanted to
just get up and walk after spending like
four hours doing nothing at the computer
and
like the bosses just would not have it
they just wanted to have a body in the
seat
they didn't really care how that body
was doing they just wanted the person in
the seat and that was it what were they
paying you guys
so
they were paying us about thirty
thousand dollars um it was originally 28
working in the graphic violence division
per month
per month
i wish it was per year they're paying
you 30 grand a year
yes
to watch all okay
okay they're paying you 30 a year and
that's like 15 bucks an hour is what
they're paying you okay
um
so so these are two separate companies
now let me ask you is the liability
is a liability on facebook or is a
liability on
cognizant technology solutions and
how is facebook holding these guys
accountable for doing their job right uh
so that's an easy question to answer
facebook is not holding them accountable
in fact it was cognizant that was the
one that backed out of the deal with
facebook about being a vendor for their
content
facebook was not holding them
accountable at all cognizant was able to
do whatever they wanted without really
any interference
as long as a certain amount of content
was being uh looked at every single day
that's all that they cared about
they really didn't even care much about
the accuracy ratings they just wanted
the number to go up to say we looked at
this much content
that was really what they were focusing
on what's successful what percentage is
successful to them
so a percentage that was successful them
is they wanted each and every employee
to do about 500 to 1 000 pieces of
content every day
and
i was usually doing about 100 to 200
contents on usually a day where there
was not much going on because
going through this content
when you're in a specialized area you
have to not only just action it you have
to go through the internet find out the
source of it if you can find it
verify if it's real or not make sure you
have the links make sure you you say how
you found it and then write up a report
on it
so a great example would be like i'm
finding a lot of these terrible
bestiality videos
and i was able to find a bestiality
website and i was able to find those
same videos from there so i was able to
find the source of it there
so then i would write up a report saying
that this was not an original facebook
piece of content this was something that
was taken from another website and then
i would write up my report saying why it
would be taken down
what the actions would be what it breaks
in the policy so that does take up a
good amount of time especially when
you're basically going through the whole
internet looking for a piece of content
like that
but there were a lot of times when my
trainers would tell me
go slow do it you're doing great that's
why we promoted you and then i would
have the team leader telling me no you
need more content more content more
content done
and so i was getting two different
perspectives on what i needed to do
there there was one that was telling me
i needed bigger number
of content and then i had another
group of people telling me that i needed
to just focus on the accuracy of what i
was doing because these were
real people real animals in these
situations
it was really pretty much the ethical
side versus the business side i'm
looking at this tampa bay times article
that says facebook agrees to pay 52
million dollars settlement with content
moderators who suffer trauma on the job
former and current moderators in florida
and across the country will receive a
thousand dollars each and may be
eligible for more money to cover medical
treatments and damages etc etc
uh is this did you see this actually
become a reality like did you guys see
payment from facebook on this 52 million
uh no i believe it's still in court
right now still actually being worked on
um casey newton from the verge uh told
me that he wanted me to be a part of it
and so i decided i will be i originally
didn't want to because i didn't want
anybody to come across thinking that i'm
just doing like coming out and saying
all this stuff
like there's a message i wanted to bring
about this
but um i decided that it probably would
be best especially after everything
that's happened to me
and then there's another article that
says a total of 556 employees will be
laid off early next year from a
controversial facility near carrollwood
that monitors facebook for banned
content such as hate speech bullying
threats and videos of violence against
criminals and children
violence against animals and children
cognizant technology solution a
contractor
for facebook plans to close its
operations at 7725
woodland center boulevard about two
miles north of tampa bay tampa
international airport is that the
facility you were at the center this is
the facility crazy so so you you
remember when this story came out
because this is two years ago a year and
a half ago give or take i do remember
that story coming out
so they so you said
cognizant technology solutions dropped
facebook
yes why did they drop facebook if it's
an account that's paying you good money
i believe it was just the bad amount of
publicity that they were getting i got
last i heard about it is their stocks
were starting to drop and there was a
lot of negative news going on about how
they were being how they were treating
everybody by being a vendor for facebook
so
they decided just to drop the account
all together is this the same cognizant
uh company that's a publicly traded
company doing like 16 billion a year
like doing uh uh revenue is yeah 16.65
and 22. is this the company like that's
the company yes got it interesting so
i'm sure they don't want that kind of
publicity to be tied to that is that is
that their business model though like do
they do this also for twitter youtube
facebook linkedin other sites as well or
was this like a singular project that
they took with facebook
as what i was specifically told is that
it was not in florida but it was in
texas there was another branch of
cognizant that was doing the same thing
we were doing but instead of facebook
instagram it was twitter
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]